und wir wechseln das thema und schauen
auf die masken pflichte die soll im
flugzeug jetzt abgeschafft werden ab
herbst dann wird sie aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz gestrichen aber
eine hintertür die gibt es noch denn
sobald die korona fallzahlen wieder hoch
gehen soll bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach die möglichkeit haben
den masken zwang wieder schnell
einzuführen und jetzt ist der
gesundheitsminister vor die presse
getreten und hat die details dieser
neuen maßnahmen erläutert ja doch
zunächst muss er die frage beantworten
warum jetzt im flugzeug die masken denn
fallen sollen bei internationalen flügen
wird da hat er so gut wie keine maske
mehr getragen da sind die maßnahmen
gelockert worden die lufthansa hat immer
wieder vorgetragen dass sie die masken
pflicht in flugzeuge nicht mehr umsetzen
kann sie wären nicht nur nicht mehr
kontrollierbar sondern auch nicht mehr
also erzwingen war nicht mehr umsetzbar
daher haben wir davon abstand genommen
und reduzieren uns auf die bereiche im
inland wo das möglich ist und darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit bild meinung
schärfe philippi ad hoc schönen guten
tag findet was sagst du zu sein aussagen
findest du das konsequent im flugzeug
sollen die masken fallen aber in der
bahn sollen sie weiterhin getragen
werden also zunächst einmal finde ich
ist völlig richtig dass im flieger die
maske natürlich fällt aber das was wir
von karl lauterbach jetzt gehört haben
die gründe die begründung dafür warum
die masken pflicht fällt das zeigt
einfach dass es mittlerweile eine
komplette corona regel willkür gibt es
gibt nämlich keinen wirklichen grund
dafür dass man im flugzeug eine maske zu
tragen hat und
nicht mehr tragen muss umzug weiterhin
doch dem cover sagt karl otto bacher
karl lauterbach sagt die menschen tragen
die masken nicht mehr die lufthansa kann
das nicht mehr umsetzen kann es nicht
mehr kontrollieren also erstens das galt
natürlich auch vor monaten schon wer
auch vor einigen monaten schon geflogen
ist hat auch bemerkt dass die menschen
die masken nicht mehr tragen wollen das
hat sich auch nicht sonderlich verändert
und da hat sich auch die lage der
lufthansa nicht verändert denn der wahre
grund dafür dass diese masken pflicht
dem flugzeug fällt das ist ein ganz
anderer der liegt einfach daran dass
robert habeck und olaf scholz erwischt
wurden wie sie zwar mit negativen pcr
test aber ohne maske im
regierungsflieger waren zusammen mit
vielen anderen journalisten das hat für
einen politischen eklat gesorgt und die
fdp hat dieses momentum genutzt um die
masken pflicht im flugzeug zu kippen und
karl lauterbach hält natürlich weiter an
der masken pflicht im zug fest jetzt
kann man natürlich sagen im flugzeug
sind aber andere filter anderer
luftfilter installiert und deswegen ist
es etwas sicherer als im zug aber das
galt bislang ja auch schon also wenn man
jetzt zu beginn des herbstes die masken
pflicht im flugzeug gibt dann heißt es
dass sie auch bislang nicht notwendig
war und ehrlich gesagt wenn man mal
beispielsweise aus dem ausland nach
deutschland rein fährt mit dem zug so
wie ich das vor kurzem gemacht habe aus
österreich nach deutschland rein das
erste was man hört sobald man auf
deutschem boden ist ist ein bitte ziehen
sie die maske an und dann sitzt er der
volle ece der ohne maske und zieht sich
dann die maske wieder an das ist doch
einfach nur schwachsinn ehrlich gesagt
das hat keinerlei wissenschaftliche
begründung und wir sehen ja auch das
corona gerade einfach überhaupt kein
großes problem ist auch nicht im sommer
war die krankenhäuser füllen sich nicht
mit corona patienten man weiß überhaupt
nicht wie viele menschen tatsächlich
wegen corona noch schwer erkranken nicht
einfach nur mit corona ins krankenhaus
kommen also diese ganzen vernünftigen
die begründung die wir gerade gehört
haben von kalotte machen dass ich die
regel nicht umsetzen lässt nicht
kontrollieren lässt nicht erzwingen
lässt ja das stimmt aber das gilt auch
für ganz viele andere chor ohne regeln
und das was die regierung hier gemacht
hat mit der maske pflicht und flieger
sollte sie auch einfach ausweiten auf
ganz viele andere bereiche und in die
begründung von karl lauterbach wollen
wir jetzt noch mal reinhören
so wie jetzt zeitpunkt ist das tragen
von masken in den bussen und bahnen
sinnvoll und notwendig bei flugzeug ist
die lage etwas anders weil leucht die
filteranlagen in den flugzeugen
natürlich mehr luftzirkulation
herrscht auf der anderen seite kann es
auch sein dass im herbst die fahrt
zahlen stark steigen dann könnten wir
als regierung per verordnung auch in den
flugzeugen die masken pflicht im
flugzeug wieder einführen also eine
hintertür lässt er sich immer noch offen
dass er also wenn die fallzahlen wieder
steigen die rolle rückwärts macht
absolut die hintertür für eine
verschärfung die ohne die kann karl
lauterbach natürlich nicht also
verschärfen muss immer irgendwie möglich
sein notfalls per verordnung aber wenn
wir da jetzt reinhören im flugzeug sind
andere filter ja aber die wurden ja
jetzt nicht spontan eingebaut die machen
ja die ganze zeit da also wenn man jetzt
die masken pflicht im flugzeug was sagen
dass ich dass ich hier lachen muss dass
man sieht einfach wie man versucht ein
politisches manöver irgendwie halbwegs
wissenschaftlich zu begründen aber wie
gesagt die die filter in den flugzeugen
die anderen besseren filter die waren ja
immer schon da die wurden nicht jetzt
eingebaut es gibt keinen
wissenschaftlichen grund dass man jetzt
im flugzeug die masken nicht aufhebt
aber im zug weiter was getragen muss und
wenn man zug fährt dann sieht man doch
dass viele menschen die maske auch nicht
tragen wollen es wird ja auch ständig
gegessen und getrunken ohne maske die
leute sitzen ja auch völlig zurecht
masken frei im bordbistro und das wird
alles über das luft system ja weiter
verbreitet also wer den ersten schritt
macht und die masken pflicht im flugzeug
auf etwas völlig richtig ist der muss
aber auch bitte dann den zweiten schritt
gehen und die maske pflicht im zug
aufheben und natürlich wird herr
lauterbach das nicht machen wollen aber
es gibt ja immer noch die fdp die kann
zeigen dass sie die partei der freiheit
ist und endlich dafür sorgen dass die
masten pflicht schritt für schritt
überall gibt hältst du das für
realistisch dass der zweite schritt
gegangen wird also dass die massen
pflicht in der bahn auch jetzt in den
nächsten wochen clip wird
das hängt alles vom politischen momentum
ab es werden gewiss die korona
fallzahlen wieder steigen also die
infektionszahlen und dann wird natürlich
wieder das sogenannte team vorsicht
kommen und sagen oh jetzt müssen wir
doch weiter vorsichtig aber man kann
nicht einfach nur weil mehr menschen
sich mit irgendetwas infizieren
maßnahmen für alle verhängen und
deswegen sollte die regierung meiner
meinung nach hier auf jeden fall den
zweiten schritt gehen für die fdp wird
das natürlich nicht leicht sein dass es
die fdp hat nicht alleine die die
mehrheit aber die union sagt dass uns ja
auch die fdp sagt die weiß auch dass das
quatsch ist dass das im zug bleibt mir
sagen ganz viele politiker hinter der
hand von mir aus kann alles weg deswegen
ja die zahlen werden steigen wir werden
aber sehen dass dass deutschland nicht
in einen notlage bringt und spätestens
wenn wir das sehen dann sollten die
letzten corinna regeln fallen sagt bild
meinung chef philippe piatti herzlichen
dank für das gespräch
[Musik]